When we're looking at data sources, the easiest
first place to start is existing data sets.
Conceptually, the easiest way to
do this is with in-house data,
also in terms of existing data, there's
open data and there's third-party data.
I'll talk about the pros and
cons of each of these briefly.
In-house data can be fast and easy because it's
already there. It might be in the proper format
and, if you're lucky, it's documented properly.
On the other hand, in-house data may not be
subject to the kind of quality control that data
that's intended for other people might have. Also,
there might be restrictions or policies on the
data use even within a particular organization.
So, let's look at some of the pros and cons of
in-house data. The first pro is potentially it's
very quick, easy, and should be free because
you're within the same organization. If you're
lucky, there's standardized formatting
that the organization has instituted,
rules or policies about this is the way we do it.
Also, if you're very lucky, the original team that
gathered the data and processed it should still
be available. Makes your life very easy when you
want to answer questions and get insights.
Sometimes, identifiers might be available,
and what that means is you might actually know
the identity of each respondent or case in it.
There are, however, some cons. First off
is the data you need simply may not exist.
It may be the organization never gathered that
data. Also, the documentation may be inadequate.
Often when organizations are gathering
their own data, they get it together,
they use it for what they need to, and then
they kind of store it off to the side but it's
hard to tell what's what. And also, the quality
of the data may be uncertain. You may not know
about response biases or errors in coding and that
makes it a little harder to work with it reliably.
An alternative to in-house data is open data.
This prepared data that's freely available.
Usually, it's government data but
there's also some open corporate data.
And there's a move towards more
and more open scientific data.
Now the pros here are that you can get enormous
data sets. You could get terabytes, possibly even
petabytes, that are worth millions of dollars.
You can get a very wide range of topics.
You can get them covering various historical times
and trends, and the data from open data is often
well formatted and well documented. The cons of
open data are that you potentially have biased
samples, in that the samples may be restricted to
a particular geographic area or maybe restricted
only to people that have internet access, and
those can create problems with interpretation.
Also, the meaning of the variables may not be
clear. You don't have the opportunity to talk
with the people who gathered the data and it's
sometimes hard to understand why or how they
defined a particular variable the way they
did. Also, in some situations open data may
stipulate that you need to share your analyses.
That open data is there for open analytics.
That might be an issue and something you
need to look at carefully before you dive in.
Finally, openness and data can conflict with the
needs of privacy and confidentiality in data.
Finally, there's third-party data, or what
we call data as a service, DaaS. These people
are also called data brokers and you can get a
huge amount of data on a large range of topics.
Also, many of these data brokers
will also process the data to make
certain kinds of inferences for you
which can save you a lot of time.
So, the pros of third-party data is that
they can save you a lot of time and effort.
They often give you individual-level data.
And you can get summaries and inferences.
On the other hand, third-party data can be
very, very expensive. Also, it may still
require validation. You still need to double
check that it means what you think it means.
And probably most significantly, third-party
data is often very distasteful to many people.
So, our conclusion. Exercise care in interpreting
data because there's always the possibility of
implicate biases or simply because you weren't
there when it got gathered, it may not mean
exactly what you think it means. That being
said, you can get enormous amounts of information
and you can save yourself a lot of time in your
data science projects by using existing data sets.